Did you hear that they might have uncovered a Pedo ring?
He might've uncovered a Pedo ring when he was doing this.
Oh,
Jen did?
No,
Sasha Baron Cohen.
Oh Wow.
Oh yeah.
Did you see it?
I read a headline that says that you're fine with the exact specifics of it
were,
but like they decided not to air it,
but it's like what dude?
You know what,
when you said that about Oj made me think I met Buzz Aldrin from the moon.
Yes.
And He,
and when I met him,
it didn't seem like he'd been to the moon.
Not Saying that Colin.
Yeah.
Hold on a second.
Uh,
sent cut.
Who is America interview to FBI over fears of Las Vegas pedophile route and not
surprised.
Whoa.
Said the said the interview led him to believe there could be a pedophile ring
in Las Vegas.
Holy Shit.
Could you imagine of a pedophile ring in Las Vegas was exposed by Sasha Baron
Cohen and a comedy movie and they find out it's real.
I wonder if this is all,
this is a setup for some other type of film,
but let's look at it.
Okay.
There has to have been pedophile rings in the past.
Undeniable.
Right.
I would think if you go back,
you go back to like the 50s or the forties and the 30s there has to be something
like that easy back then.
Yeah.
They take orphans and they molest him.
All that Sandusky type shit that has been going on.
Yeah.
So how often has it been going on and what happens now to the same type of
people?
Like if that's no longer available for them,
is there some way they get it,
some super fucking super tightly watched circuit ring of people who still engage
in this activity and figured out a way to do it?
I hope not.
I hope not too.
Everybody hopes not,
but the idea that it's impossible.
The idea that it's impossible is unlikely.
Yeah.
There's probably a market for it,
sadly.
Well you think about it all the time when you think about other countries,
right?
Yeah.
They're doing it.
They're for sure.
Most of our guys,
it seems fly over these other countries and be dirty over there.
The idea of like going over there and there's a ring,
a pedophile ring.
Ooh,
that's scary dude.
Who wants to fuck some kid?
That's crazy.
They think it's mostly people who have been abused like that themselves.
Yeah,
it's mostly that.
That's one of the things that Kevin Spacey's brothers said about Kevin is that
Kevin is basically like their dad and their dad sexually abused them and now
Kevin is acting that out and there was a,
an interview.
His Dad,
his brother rather give us he,
Kevin Spacey's brother and I never met Rod Stewart on the strongest acid
available.
Oh,
he's crazy looking.
This is weird looking guy with wacky hair and he wears funky glasses and weird
clothes.
Donnie,
what's his name?
I don't know what his name is,
but he looks like he's wearing a costume.
Donny space.
That's not it,
is it?
No,
but here it took a look at them.
Just look at this.
That's,
that's his brother.
God Dang Man.
It looks like Nice Guy.
Seemed like an English scientist and Rod Stewart.
I can't believe Kevin's when they got banged by the day.
I think they both did.
I think you saying they both did.
I can't believe I even just said that.
It's messed up.
Yeah,
it's sad,
man.
They said their dad was a monster.
Yeah.
Look at his dad like,
look,
look at this.
His brother,
how he dresses up.
Look at that crazy rod Stewart outfit.
Yeah,
I bet.
Like one chick or one dude fucked him because he thought it was rod Stewart and
it's like,
look,
I'm just going to ride this boat riding to the rocks,
right,
Stuart.
Huh?
This is his outfit.
That's crazy.
Outfit.
That has a crazy,
crazy outfit.
He's got rings on every finger.
He's got a wallet chain across his Pecker.
Wow.
Those dicks keeping time brother.
Yeah.
Look at that shirt.
That fluffy shirt with the crazy ass neck accouterments.
Yeah.
If you're not trying to get fucked by somebody,
you shouldn't wear all this happened and,
but,
but think about how much effort it took to do all this.
And I'll go up to his teeth,
son.
Yeah,
What's up with that mug at Scotland,
Bro?
Clean that shit up.
Is he from Scotland?
It's Kevin Spacey from Scotland.
I think they're from Britain.
I think they're from America.
Really?
Yeah.
Where was Kevin Spacey born?
Fuck,
if you'd know you're googling it.
Well you know for a year then you're the guy who's got the Google in front of
you.
But no,
what about this?
Do you think he would have been as talented but he didn't have this affliction?
Where does it say does this any worries from Orange,
New Jersey?
See there you go.
Perfect.
Dump and pop.
One of those talented men of our time.
People like in New Jersey who fuck you bro.
Man,
I was born there.
He is very talented but he's also very crazy and I think,
uh,
in his day you could get away with a lot if you're a movie star.
I think,
you know,
they just,
they ran those sets like,
oh yeah,
they were crazy.
Well they have that are Kelly thing now and in that have got his whole life,
he got to do whatever you wanted.
It seemed like that's a different animal.
Right?
Cause he's a musician.
But yeah,
it seems like he's the under age.
The underage thing with him is like Aaliyah married,
Aaliyah,
underage sex with her underage,
and it was till I remember we just grew up listening to his music.
It was these girls are coming out about him doing that to them when they're,
yeah,
but a lot of people new 1314,
they're saying 15,
but I can't believe more people aren't comes up.
Let's say there was a video of it,
you know that more people aren't complicit in that.
It was unbelievable.
What about the people that are like,
well here's what's crazy.
Did the video is out of him peeing on people and then years later people are
still making music with them.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
When you find out how many people were,
what was it?
Was it the breakfast club?
What show was it that they,
uh,
they started reading off a list of all the people that worked with our Kelly
post video.
So the video was out,
Lady Gaga,
all these people and he like a giant number of people.
Do you think we'll ever be able to eradicate the,
the fact that people do that too,
like,
uh,
have like the pedophile or had that vibe for them first to sexual sexualized
children or young people.
Hopefully scientists will figure out a way to isolate that part of human
thinking someday.
Like hopefully there'll be something researchers,
doctors,
scientists,
psychologist,
whoever.
It is figured out a way to stop that.
But in the meantime,
what had has gotten is way more difficult for them to get away with it.
Right,
right.
And it's going to get more difficult still.